clamecy 4000 habitants d'année en année
la commune voit son paysage se
transforme et un service public amoindri
qui se fait ressentir dès l'arrivée dans
la ville
le guichet de la gare est ouvert une
seule fois par semaine il est même voit
disparaître un sentiment d'abandon qui
ne date pas d'hier c'est plusieurs
décennies mais on nous oublie dans
l'aménagement du territoire dans
l'aménagement des routes et dans les
voies ferrées plus nous oublie dans ces
domaines et moins on a de facilité à
développer des zones d'activités
économiques
ça compte énormément alors qu il fait si
bon vivre chez nous il fait bon vivre
mais dans de mauvaises conditions
les habitants sont les premiers touchés
par les augmentations successives des
taxes suis fonctionnaire
le salaire moyen moi ça fait peine
quatre ans je travaille je suis à 1300
euros net par mois 1
si j'étais tout ça je pourrais pas vivre
je pourrais pas vivre les gens qui ont
un smig pour vivre à l'heure actuelle
quand ils vont arriver à la retraite
que vont ils avoir jusque et services
que ça soit hospitalier services
administratifs où ces services là où ont
tendance à disparaître légèrement ou
alors à être décalés dans des villes
plus grande donc obligés de faire des
kilomètres pour y aller l'hôpital public
est un des fondements qui résistent ou
du moins qui essayent alain marché
infirmiers urgentistes s'est battu
longtemps il a vu disparaître la
maternité et le service de chirurgie
aujourd'hui il vit avec la peur de voir
un nouveau service disparaître à balayer
plus rien plus rien dans cette aile là
il n'y a plus rien c'était la chirurgie
c'est des pièces inoccupées et servent à
rien pour l'instant
l'aspiq la médecine mais l'urgence c'est
vraiment le minimum quoi
après si on a plus ça c'est 50 km à côté
pour aller resserre soixante dix pour
aller à la mer à 10 kilomètres de là le
maire de varzy se bat pour éviter la
fermeture du centre des finances
publiques
car même si en 2018 tout se fait par
internet ce village de 1500 habitants a
du mal à passer le cap du numérique
ici en plein centre-ville à vous avez de
l'internet mais vous allez à 2km j'en
avais plus c'est pas tenable ces
affaires là c'est pas tenable mais nous
on fait les démarches à pied ici à varzy
comme ailleurs sûrement clamecy symbole
d'une france fracture et
géographiquement et numériquement une
société des villes face à une société
des champs un territoire marqué par un
sentiment d'abandon
où l'accès aux services devient de plus
en plus compliqué